the Walt Disney Company is reportedly
planning a massive cost cutting measures
including some layoffs all eyes have
been on this
[Music]
Bob tree practice
this is where our magic comes from
Disney Plus
on February 25th 2020 Bob chapek was
promoted to being CEO of Walt Disney was
doing better than ever before they had
just released a Frozen 2 a few months
ago and it was a breaking box office
records left and right meanwhile Disney
plus had just been launched three months
ago and it was growing faster than even
Disney could imagine people were
watching more movies than ever traveling
more than ever and the covid was just
something that you read about on the
news but just 17 days after his
promotion the United States would enter
a national lockdown and enter one of the
most unprecedented times in history of
National Emergency overnight all of
Disney Parks were shut down no one was
watching Disney movies in theaters and
Disney couldn't even produce their films
in person Disney had entered one of the
worst crises in its history and the man
of the home had been there for a
whopping at 17 days over the next two
years Disney would experience some of
their lowest lowest and some of their
highest highs Disney plus would rock it
to over 100 million subscribers putting
Netflix to shame but at the same time
there are multi 100 million dollar parks
would be completely deserted like some
Wasteland despite the Glorious highs and
terrible lows it seemed like Disney was
overall on the right track by mid-2021
Disney stock was setting new all-time
highs crossing over 200 billion dollars
in market cap but all of this would
change in 2022 the first signs of a
recession could be seen Over the Horizon
and as people pulled back on spending
Disney would be hit harder than the
pandemic day after day Disney would put
in a new 52-week low new 52-week low new
52-week low in fact they would return to
their pandemic lows and it turned out
that Disney plus wasn't nearly as
successful as the media had led us to
believe subscriber numbers were
plummeting the platform was losing
billions and that there were even signs
that there may have been some my
counting fraud obviously shareholders
were Furious and at the end of 999 days
it was decided that Bob chapek had done
more harm than good and in November of
2022 Bob chapek would be fired from
being a Disney CEO to rub assault in the
wound his replacement would be his
predecessor Bob Iger something that
Disney fans would celebrate Bob Iger is
returning to the Walt Disney Company as
chief executive officer so here's Bob
chapek's tumultuous 999 days at the top
and why he was really fired from the top
job
foreign
allegedly discovered that Bob chapek was
cooking the books to hide the massive
losses of Disney plus and it's not
surprising why he would do this he had
just taken over our CEO during one of
the worst periods of the company's
history and if you wanted to stick
around and impress shareholders he had
to put up impressive numbers but that
was nearly impossible when half of your
business is shut down and the other half
is charging super low subscription fees
just to get people in the door so chapek
allegedly turned to the good old fudge
the numbers and hope no one notices
strategy honestly it was quite clever
what he did he didn't just pull numbers
out of tenere or make up numbers instead
he would rearrange some expenses to make
certain parts of the business look
better than they really were the best
example of this was with the two TV
series called The Mysterious Benedict
Society ended Doogie Kami Aloha MD the
production cost of the series is not
known but it was likely in the tens of
millions if we we call it 50 million
each we have a total production cost of
about 100 million dollars and there's
also marketing on top of that but
chatback apparently found a clever way
to offload this cost from Disney plus
you see it he would air these shows on
the Disney Channel slightly before
airing them on Disney plus this way he
could write off the marketing and
production expenses of the show as a
Disney Channel expense as opposed to a
Disney plus expense so instead of
costing 50 million for Disney plus it
appeared that it only cost 20 or 30
million he was marking down the right
numbers he was just cleverly spreading
the cost across Disney's various media
sectors but while clever this is also
extremely misleading investors are
suddenly led to believe that these shows
achieved an extraordinary Roi in terms
of cost per severe ship for example this
tactic made it seem like launching
movies on Disney plus was more worth it
than it really was if a 10 million
dollar show was able to Garner this much
watch Time Imagine what a 150 million
dollar Flagship movie could bring in the
truth is not much while streaming
platforms are a great way to earn
recurring revenue on movies that have
already had their run in theaters it's a
terrible way to monetize new releases
but due to this potential funny business
they would allow for movies like Seoul
disenchanted and Hocus Pocus 2 to
directly launch on Disney plus and a
given that Japan couldn't do any sleight
of hand with these big name films it
didn't take long for investors to
realize the truth about the Disney plus
and let's just say Disney is now taking
the exact opposite approach when it
comes to Bringing movies to Disney plus
with Avatar 2 for example Disney hasn't
even provided a Disney plus release time
frame it's rumored though that it won't
come out till July or 7 months after the
initial release if chapek didn't
allegedly play with the numbers maybe
Executives could have come to this
conclusion way quicker like Universal
Studios did with the James Bond no time
to die but instead they ended up
releasing big budget films on Disney
plus ended losing a bunch of money not
only is chapek's supposed actions
misleading but in court it could be
argued to be Securities fraud after all
misleading investors is against SEC
rules and regulations but that's not
where the story ends as Disney plus
wasn't the only place where some funny
business may have occurred
foreign
to whistleblower Sandy Kuba Disney was
also cooking the books with their Disney
parks for years well before chapek took
over as CEO but that doesn't mean that
chat pack is in the clear because guess
what chapek's job was before he became
CEO well he was the chairman of Disney
parks and Resorts since 2015. so it
doesn't seem like the Disney plus thing
was his first offense according to Sandy
Koopa this new was religiously implied
counting tricks to overstated park
revenues here are some of the tricks
that Disney allegedly leveraged you know
how sometimes you can get gift cards for
discounted prices for example you might
be able to get a 500 gift card for 395
or something well Disney regularly sells
gift cards for discounts but instead of
recording the amount that customers
actually paid for the gift card Disney
would allegedly just record the face
value of the gift card and when you're
talking about gift cards that are
regularly discounted by 20 you're
constantly overstating your gift card
Revenue You by 20 this wasn't the only
gift card trip that Disney had up their
sleeve either whenever they gave out
free gift cards to angry customers well
that was apparently counted as earned
Revenue as well also Disney would
supposedly count the revenue of each
gift card twice once when it was
purchased and once when it was used it
seems like some of these tricks didn't
just apply to gift cards either it
appears that Disney was regularly
marking down all sorts of complementary
items as earned revenue for example
let's say you booked a hotel with Disney
and received a complimentary round of
golf that's valued at a hundred dollars
Disney would apparently Mark this down
as earned Revenue even though you didn't
pay anything for it also it's not like
someone was manually making these
changes on the Fly these tricks were
apparently baked into the software
itself making it easy to systematically
overstate revenue by billions of dollars
and nearly impossible to detect without
being an Insider Sandy would of course
try to sort out these issues internally
At first she tried contacting senior
Executives and the auditing team but
they obviously didn't do anything other
than threaten her they informed her that
if she reported her concerns about the
company's practices elsewhere Disney
would consider it a retaliation against
the company honestly it would have been
in Sandy's best interest to just keep
quiet but she would decide to do the
brave thing and report it to the SEC I
don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that she was fired shortly after the SEC
filing was made it's not clear what
exactly the SEC has been doing with this
case since then but it's definitely not
anything notable so for all we know
Disney could still be leveraging such
tactics to this day also according to
Sandy the worst of it was during the
2008 financial crisis when Disney may
have overstated their revenues by as
much as 6 billion dollars for
perspective Disney's total Park revenue
in 2009 was 10.6 billion which means
that as much as 60 percent of this
Revenue may have been fraudulent with
that being said it we just crossed an
even at worst period for Disney parks in
2020 and 2021 so who knows how much
trickery may have been happening behind
the scenes
foreign
as you can see fighting numbers with the
Disney plus may have just been the
latest in the history of bending the
rules for Bob chapek but it was the
first time that he faced any real
consequences the SEC went ahead and find
Disney for I'm just kidding did you
really think the SEC would do anything
best case scenario they might find
Disney for 100 million or something the
real consequences for chapek were dealt
by the board and shareholders I don't
think the board cared much about the
fudging of the numbers other than the
fact that it makes them look bad but
something that they do care about is the
bottom line and the chapek wasn't able
to deliver on the bottom line in fact he
not only didn't deliver but he put up
some atrocious numbers which may have
been fudged to begin with so in reality
these numbers are probably worse than
reported but here's what the reported
number suggest right before chapic got
fired Disney plus reported a loss of 1.5
billion dollars in a single quarter this
simply make up for this current burn
rate Disney needs 62 and a half million
people to join Disney plus and not watch
anything at all forever this may have
sounded at least a bit reasonable two
years ago when everyone was joining due
to the pandemic but now the exact
opposite is happening in the most recent
quarter Disney plus reported a
subscriber loss of 2.4 million last year
people were calling Netflix dead for
losing subscribers for the first time in
10 years and even that was only 500 000.
Disney plus over here is losing nearly
five times that amount after just being
out for a mere three years yeah I don't
think it was very difficult for the
board to give chapek the ax it just so
happened to be exactly 999 days after
chapek took over for topic this was
probably quite humiliating and terrible
for his reputation but in terms of
compensation it worked out quite well he
was handed out a generous 20 million
despite driving Disney stock back to
pandemic lows making Disney plus a money
pit and and potentially misleading
investors for years in the meantime
Disney is looking to their former CEO
Bob Iger to work his magic once again
Iker was the one behind all of the
Acquisitions that Disney is known for
today including Pixar Marvel lucasfilma
and the 21 Century Fox so Disney is
hoping that Iger can pull off a miracle
for Disney plus as well but only time
will tell but that's the Dark Truth
About Bob chapek and why he was really
fired after just 909 days as a CEO would
you pay for Disney plus comment that
down below also drop a like if you would
also like a 20 million Severance and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest for the video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
thank you
[Music]